500000 saluons vient de passer les cinq
cent mille abonnés sur la chaîne vous
êtes 500000 ici à regarder les vidéos et
âme avoir rejoint c'est assez
vertigineux ça fait deux jours et on est
même exactement à 512 1268 merci juste
merci beaucoup quand j'ai réfléchi à la
vidéo qu'on allait faire pour fêter ça
parce que autant vous le dire il y avait
rien de prévu c'est arrivé beaucoup trop
vite je pensais que ça arriverait les
500 milles abonnés peut-être mois de
septembre octobre novembre
là j'étais un petit peu pris de court
tout début je me suis je me forcer à
regarder mes anciennes vidéos et j'aime
filmer il commenté en même temps et je
me suis vraiment demandé s'il y avait un
intérêt à faire ça
j'en ai pas réellement trouvé il ya plus
de 400 vidéos sur cette chaîne que j'ai
lancé le 1er janvier 2016 d'ailleurs si
des fois vous demander si j'ai parlé
d'un sujet particulier taper dans la
barre de recherche google olicard suivi
du sujet que vous chercher pour voir si
elle pas une vidéo déjà dessus et bref
jeudi soir dans mon lit quand on a passé
le cap des 500 mille personnes sur cette
chaîne j'ai eu une idée vous faire un
test avec six personnes cinq six
personnes dont une personne ment et vous
devez retrouver qui est la personne qui
mange et donc ni un message temporaire
sur facebook pour vous recruter
pour ceux qui me suivent bien sûr sur
facebook pour les autres vous avez les
liens dans la description et j'ai
demandé à philippe roesch de participer
pour pas que ce soit moi que je reste en
retrait du truc les six personnes que
vous allez voir participer qui sont des
abonnés de la chaîne se sont mis
d'accord entre eux pour choisir qui
allaient mentir ou pas mentir il va y
avoir plusieurs histoires philippe
essayer de trouver mais vous aussi
évidemment essayer de trouver qui est le
menteur ou qui est la menteuse
[Musique]
salut aujourd'hui on va jouer à un jeu
de vérités de mensonges que vous allez
devoir déterminer si quelqu'un dit la
vérité aussi quelqu'un il ya quelqu'un
qui va essayer de faire en live c'est
philippe roche et forcément il nous faut
des cobayes est un [ __ ] mais paul
jordan audrey et natacha ça va se passer
en deux étapes pour la première étape
ils vont tous nous dira un souvenir de
vacances sauf une personne qui va mentir
pour le premier essai je vais pas vous
donner de clés je te donne pas de clé à
toi non plus donc peut-être que tu vas
trouver peut-être que vous allez trouver
aussi ils vont tous dire en quelques
mots un souvenir de vacances sauf une
personne qui ment on sait pas encore
laquelle il ya quelques mois de ça en
février je suis parti à new york
j'étais petit en début d'année partir
d'échangés universitaires et j'ai pu
faire un voyage en laponie
j'ai gagné à grâce à un concours offert
par l'armée un baptême de l'air
l'an dernier pendant mon voyage au pérou
j'ai nagé avec hellion mais ray 13 ans
je suis parti à mayotte pendant un mois
comment repréciser les personnes qui
étaient avec moi pour montrer ses
vacances ça ressemble à quoi un lion de
mer par rapport aux buttes chaumont
comment c'était c'était new york un
message spécial c'était central park ah
oui c'était bien
en février j'ai en plus donc alors
philippe tu as posé des questions à tout
le monde je pense que tu as un avis
maintenant je pense que vous aussi
derrière votre écran vous avez un avis
d'après toi qui monte
or pour moi c'est audrey les lions de
mer les otaries je sais pas j'ai un
doute là dessus
est-ce que tu mens tu es non je suis
vraiment parti au pérou et j'ai vraiment
nager avec vire au maire est ce que la
personne qui mentaient peut lever la
main oui c'était jordan
oui ce premier c'est n'est pas une
réussite pour philippe peut-être qu'il
est une réussite pour vous sauf que pour
le deuxième essai philippe il va avoir
une petite formation accélérée c'est la
page 97
je te laisse ouvrir pour l'instant eux
ils l'ont pas lu donc ils savent pas ce
que ça va être en fait tes clés que vous
les aiderez à la fin les clés évidemment
[Musique]
est ce que tu te sens un peu plus armé
deuxième essai deuxième test aussi bien
pour vous que pour philippe secousse ils
vont tous vous raconter un truc de ouf
qui leur est arrivé
sauf une personne qui va mentir alors
quand je suis rentré de new york du coup
invasion il ya eu une tempête de neige
et je me suis retrouvé bloqué en islande
alors c'était pas prévu une journée
pourtant fourni sand dans un spa calais
10h boréale c'était pas du tout prix
reprendre le contexte du coup je suis
toujours dans la piscine avec mon petit
frère ma famille mon commentaire et donc
on faisait un peu trop de bruit en ce
cas pourquoi contraire ils trouvent dans
ses discussions avec les petits barons
de la pareille lors d'un voyage à los
angeles en vouloir rentrer en avion et
une suspicion de détournement d'avion
donc on a été mis sur le tarmac
commander heure avec l'intervention de
ce qui est génial c'était vraiment des
trucs de ouf et a très longtemps à tout
moment bruce willis peut on aller au
festival de cannes et
a réussi à rentrer à regarder un film
alors vous avez passé et justement en
parlant du lion de mer en allant à cette
excursion là je me suis fait arrêter par
des flics qui en fait - escorté parce
qu'avec mon ami on était sûr prendre ce
faire la quête par une otarie j'étais à
paris j'ai ma meilleure amie s'est fait
larguer par personne devant moi comme
tout à l'heure philips va pouvoir poser
des questions un petit peu tout le monde
profitez-en vaut aussi pour essayer
d'affiner votre choix et savoir qui est
le menteur ou la menteuse alors déjà je
prendrai jamais l'avion avec la plupart
d'entre eux pourquoi le fbi a vous a
fait descendre
enfin changer d'escales donc en fait on
n'a pas changé d ce cas on est restés
sur le tarmac pendant environs de 10
heures tout au bout de l'aéroport
stéphane plaza s'est passé ça s'est
passé déjà eu erreur du métro donc là
c'est une tempête de neige qui a
provoqué le sou d'une journée rentrée de
new york
je sais pourquoi je me suis fait piéger
sur le premier c'est justement la
première règle de de la page 97 on va en
profiter pour leur donner c'était quoi
la première règle de la page 90 le
regard fixe et scanne les légendes
urbaines qui dit qu'un menteur en fait
regarde toujours un petit peu ailleurs
en fait c'est plutôt l'inversé un
menteur a tendance à regarder fixement
la personne parce qu'elle a besoin de
voir de valider que vous êtes en train
d'avaler son mensonge donc elle est en
train de vous observez pour voir si vous
êtes en train d'y croire donc
effectivement le regard fixe est plus un
signe de mensonges que vérité j'ai voulu
jouer sur la distance pardon d'accord
essayé de me raconter l'histoire à
l'enlever donc j'ai fait exprès de
demander si c'était bien une escale mais
du coup il a pu me raconter assez assez
facilement l'histoire avec beaucoup de
gestuelle la gestuelle on appelle ça les
illustres en a tous plus ou moins et si
on connaît la base des illustrant d'une
personne on voit si on a plus ou moins
après fermeture par contre le fait de
raconter à l'envers on en parle aussi
dans le livre c'est déjà dur de raconter
la vérité à l'envers donc alors de
mentir alors moi j'ai encore un doute
sur le sur le premier et le dernier
récit pour moi j'ai eu plus d'hésitation
sur une histoire
avec natacha voilà donc je partirai plus
sûre sur natacha est ce que la personne
qui mentaient peut lever la main oui
c'était natacha est ce que tu avais déjà
rencontré stéphane 4 août a vraiment
tout pipeauté de a à z c'est une
histoire à moitié vrai j'ai une copine
fait de régater cbg pas là et peut-être
que vous aussi vous saviez que c'était
natacha ou pas d'ailleurs en tout cas
c'est cool d'avoir vu qu'avec deux trois
clés tu as pu a pu voir quel était le
souvenir fabriqués alors peut-être que
vous aviez trouvé l'un des deux ou les
deux ou aucun n'hésitez pas à me le dire
dans les commentaires et à m'expliquer
votre raisonnement même si vous aviez
faut c'est aussi intéressant de voir les
mauvais raisonnement parce que des fois
ça peut partir sur une bonne piste et on
peut expliquer ça on a parlé plusieurs
fois d'un chapitre sur le mensonge cas
dans le livre mais j'ai aussi fait des
vidéos sur le mensonge n'hésitez pas
justement à le taper dans la barre de
recherche vous allez vous retrouver très
rapidement un grand merci à christian
salomé à pau la jordana audrey à natacha
qui sont rendus disponibles et qui sont
venus participer à cette vidéo un grand
merci également à philippe roche
il a aussi une chaîne philippe roesch
vous mets le lien dans la description et
surtout un grand merci à vous à 500
mille fois merci merci d'être ici certes
mais aussi merci parce que depuis
quelques semaines les vidéos sont
souvent dans les tendances alors qu'on
n'est pas sur les titres en majuscules
ou put acquis coup avec deux vignettes
chelou et ça c'est vraiment grâce à vous
la dernière l'été même première des
tendances merci beaucoup comme
d'habitude si vous avez aimé vous pouvez
cliquer commenté partagez vous abonner
ciao